on the mound today for the rockies
chichi gonzalez 29 year old making his
16th start he has faced the padres
before two previous starts on one of the
4-5-0 era very few strikeouts
very few in 90 and two-thirds 53 that
means what a lot of balls in play and i
tell you what that's exactly what the
padres need to say a lot of balls in
play
two hops at mcmahon over the top and
tatissa's got chichi gonzalez in three
pitches has two outs exactly the kind of
start he wanted the rockies wanted looks
sharper leon he'll send one in the air
to right field not that deep charlie
blackmon coming in he's got it chichi
gonzalez a sixth pitch first inning the
debut in a padres uniform for jake
arrieta veteran 35 year old made his
second to last start as a cub right here
at coors field that was back on august
5th four runs nine hits season tying
three home runs he's familiar with coors
field there goes joe it's a hit and run
and a little flare into short center
field for a base hit joe gets the third
he'll hold there
and it's first and third with nobody out
in the rockies first inning blackman
with a home run in last night's game
fifth home run since the all-star break
and a liner up the middle could be two
they're coming home with it
and they've got hung up connor joe who
they'll tag out
throw to first stand back safely there
is blackman but that turns out to be a
double play
worked out very well for the padres it
went from first to third and nobody out
to now two down in the inning and a
runner at first first in second two down
here in the first inning that'll bring
up cj krohn nine for your last 15 with
runners in scoring position also on the
year 338 which is 10th in the national
league 3-1 live left center field this
is going to run all the way to the wall
black middle score story will follow him
home cj crow comes through yet again
shoot up the colorado and they continue
to get to arietta cj as hot as anybody
in baseball one strike on mcmahon and
this ball is in the left hit right
center field crow coming home to this
throw is not gonna get it three nothing
rockies couple mistakes over to middle
to plate end up changing the course of
this inning ball and two strikes here's
the pitch and trejo swings and misses
strike three went fishing and jake
arrieta ends his first inning as a padre
with a strikeout
strikeout guy only 14
strikeout raid lowest in the majors
fly ball off the bat of nola to deep
left connor joe going back it's going to
be over his head and want to hop up over
the wall that is a double with one out
for austin nolan the first hit of the
day for the padres is an extra basin two
down nola third and well myers coming up
fly ball to deep left field for myers
back goes connor joe and back goes that
ball out of the yard a two-run home run
for will myers his 14th of the year and
the padres get two back here in the top
half of the second inning rockies with a
3-2 lead over the padres will myers
helping out the friars with a two-run
blast jake arrieta will go out for his
second inning of work gonzalez went
around and he strikes out and that's the
second strikeout for arietta two down
0-2 coming and connor joe swings and
misses strike three a nine pitch second
for arietta with a couple of strikeouts
rockies go in order and we go to the top
of the third first and second now with
one out brings up manny try to fly out
to right field in the first over one on
the ground in the center field a base
hit arietta being waved around manny
machado with a single back up the middle
and the padres have erased what was a
three-run deficit where tied at three
one-two pitch this is grounded to the
right side moving left is treyo he has
it throws on to first and that retires
nola padres gonna run two ounce blackman
at first and cj crone
pitch is hit in the air to center field
grisham started back a step now comes in
still coming and he dives and can't make
the play in right center blackman keeps
running around third the throw home is
offline and charlie blackman scores
4-3 rockies that is a ball that has to
be caught no question about it he
thought that ball was going to travel
more than it really did and then all of
a sudden he realized
it is the left-hander the rookie ben
bowden on for his 33rd
appearance swung on and fish he swung
out of self-defense i think that almost
hit him is exactly right one out here in
the fourth inning for will myers
myers gets into this one out to deep
left center field back goes hampton and
that ball is gone
second home run of the day for will
myers his 15th of the year and the
padres tied up again this time four to
four one out in the fourth inning for
dom nunez
this ball lifted to deep right center
field take a good look you won't see it
for long
home run
dom nunez puts a charge into that one
his eighth home run of the year and the
rockies are back in the lead trainer and
jayce tingler on the mound and jake
arrieta is walking off the mound now and
an injury to the padres newest starting
pitcher last pitch that he threw a home
run for nunez and
uh kind of grabbing the hamstring area
stretching it out first and fully
grabbing upper left hammy one out black
men at second base and trevor story
coming up 3-1 to story trevor hits in a
mile down the line state fair
gone
touch them all time trevor's story the
rockies lead it
seven to four
number 16 for story one two pitch swung
on and stroked out towards right center
long run grisham he dives and this time
he's able to make the catch taking away
a base hit from ryan mcmahon to end this
fifth inning but the rockies get a
couple of more on trevor's story he's
too wrong
christian third two down for trent
grisham
line into left field a base hit and that
will score chronoworth from third base
rbi single for trent christian with two
outs in the sixth padres get one back
seven to five colorado
today he's grounded down to second
struck out swinging and single to right
field his last time up 2-2 pitch is
looped to left field coming on connor
joe reaches out makes the catch
as he went into a slide near the line
connor joe with a big time play for the
first down gilbert the 0-2
strike three called with a high fastball
and myers has some words for david
rackley on three pitches takes care of a
dangerous right-handed hitter 2-1
grisham hits it in the air center field
easy chance for garrett hampson he's got
it and the rockies rookie left-hander
growing before our eyes big time effort
today for lucas daniel bard
blew the save against the padres that
was monday giving a game-tying three-run
shot to trent grisham remember that he
can get wild at times
and this is
foul ground nugez has a plan
he squeezes it ball game over
and the rockies have swept the padres
[Applause]